on va plus loin avec aujourd'hui mais
côté annie va reporter indépendante
bonjour un bon soir face à vous bruno
daroux de la rédaction de france 24
bonjour brunoh bonjour à faire est ce le
début d'une vraie discussion de sortie
de crise il est évidemment trop tôt pour
le dire mais les négociateurs russes
sont arrivés à istanbul pour y
rencontrer demain leurs homologues
ukrainiens un échange qui intervient
alors que le président ukrainien
volodimir zelensky a fait plusieurs
ouvertures sur le renoncement à l'otan
sur la neutralité et même sur la
souveraineté du nom basse et de la
crimée écouter il n'y a pas ni moins à
ce jeu comprend qu'il est impossible de
forcer complètement là réussi à quitter
le territoire ukrainien cela conduirait
à la troisième guerre mondiale
je le comprends et c'est pourquoi je
parle d'un compromis existe da se
retourner là où tout a commencé et
ensuite nous essaierons de résoudre le
problème du dombass la question
compliquée du dombass qui concernant les
garanties de sécurité de neutralité et
le statut non nucléaires de notre état
nous sommes prêts à y aller
c'est le point le plus important c'était
le point principal pour la fédération de
russie aussi loin que je me souvienne et
si je me souviens bien c'est pour ça
qu'ils ont commencé la guerre c'est un
grand pas en avant vient de faire hélène
ce qui est je crois que c'est important
parce qu'ils ne cessent quand même de
tendre la main et la sq est notable
c'est qu'ils parlent en russe alors
évidemment volodymyr zelensky parle
couramment le russe il parle comme
énormément d'ukrainiens mais quand il
s'adresse quand il veut faire passer un
message et là ce que vous venez de
passer c'était pour des journalistes aux
russes il a donné une interview à quatre
journalistes russes dont un d'un grand
quotidien de moscou qui s'appelle
commerçante mais qui n'a pas été publié
parce que les autorités russes ont
refusé en interdit que ce soit publié
mais les autres journalistes russes en
dehors de la russie l'ont publié et donc
il est il voulait dire ces choses là est
la première chose moi j'ai entendu cet
extrait un tout petit peu avant ce que
vous avez diffusé il dit que son premier
but c'est de minimiser les pertes son
deuxième but c'est que la guerre dure le
moins longtemps possible et son
troisième but c'est que effectivement
comme une marée qui est montée qui est
sortie de son lit là elle redescendrait
jusque dans le dos de basse et là on
pourrait discuter c'est quand même fort
de dire ça donc là je vois pas pour
comment ça pourrait ne pas être entendus
par les négociateurs demain en boule on
aurait tort pour discuter au nom on
aurait tort bruno pour autant de
négliger ces fameuses garanties de
sécurité que ne cessent de réclamer
volodia mais allen ski pour contrepartie
à ces concessions oui bah c'est là que
ça se complique un peu parce qu'en fait
dès qu'on entre dans le détail de ce
qu'il faut mettre derrière ce terme de
neutralité en fait chacune des deux
parties à des exigences qui pour le
moment quand même un peu de mal à se
rejoindre parce que effectivement
volodymyr cnce qui il est dans une
attitude de propositions essayer de
faire bouger les choses sur le plan
diplomatique de rappeler aux russes que
voilà officiellement il a bien compris
que leur objectif c'était que l'ukraine
reste neutre donc il donne un peu d
dégage comme ça mais après quand même
aussi il explique que l'intégrité et la
souveraineté de l'ukraine doivent être
respectées même si effectivement il
lâche un peu sur le combat sans entrer
dans les détails comme
une fois que ce sera calme et voilà on
va on va discuter on verra à ce
moment-là et évidemment côté russe on
n'a pas dit d'abord qu'on qu'ont accepté
cette proposition de volodymyr zelensky
on va voir ce qui se passe demain à
istanbul mais on insiste sur le fait que
la russie veut des garanties écrites sur
le fait que jamais jamais l'ukraine ne
rejoindre l'otan et aux six sur la
dénucléarisation
du de l'ukraine ce qui est qui qui est
un fin de ma carrière et ça c'est pas un
très bon prennent d'ailleurs le fait
qu'elle n'acceptera jamais un mystère
puisqu'ils ont le seuil à 17 centrales
nucléaires civiles en ukraine le voyez
vous quand on rentre dans le détail
on n'y est pas encore on peut se
demander alors on voit bien l'objectif
de zenzile qui est de négocier de
proposer des sujets de négociation
notamment qui était au coeur de la
justification russe pour envahir le cred
côté russe on s'interroge un peu plus
est-ce que c'est simplement des
négociations n'ont pas vraiment pour
aboutir à quelque chose mais pour gagner
du temps en attendant peut-être que
l'armée russe prépare la phase d'après
en tout cas la question se pose une main
tandis qu'un permis en tout cas au
moment où la russie semble avoir intérêt
à saisir non ça c'est vous qui le dites
si l'on en juge sur voilà le lait les
difficultés l'enlisement et finalement
la réorientation vers le don base des
seuls objectifs se dire est ce que les
autorités russes ont dit effectivement
ce week end il y aurait une
réaffectation des trous plutôt vers un
ce qui peut nous apparaître à nouveau vu
de loin sur la carte comme un retrait
évidemment c'est pas comme ça que les
russes le voit c'est pas comme ça qu'ils
vont nous l'expliqué que leur propagande
va l'expliquer mais tout ce que l'on
entend aujourd'hui on l'entend de la
part de vladimir zelensky ça c'est très
important du côté russe on n'a
absolument pas l'équivalent ya pas de
symétrie on n'a pas vu ademir poutine
qui est là en train de nous faire des
vidéos pour nous dire ce qu'il veut et
c'est donc c'est beaucoup moins claire
mais ce qui est important c'est que tout
le monde se mettra à négocier à un
certain moment mais peut-être ce moment
et encore pas arriver pourquoi parce que
poutine n'a pas encore assez gagné pour
envisager un arrêt complet de
l'opération c'est comme ça c'est pour
être en force pour pouvoir négocier et
de l'autre côté oliver élèves qui
n'auraient pas assez perdu pour dire on
arrête tout et on négocie donc on est
dans cet entre deux mais de part et
d'autre y compris du côté diplomatique
emmanuel macron l'a redit la répéter la
désescalade le le souci de ne jamais
fermer la porte à cette négociation au
dialogue avec venir poutine ski transe
quand même avec ce qui a été dit par joe
biden ce week-end cette phrase qui lui
avait échappé eh oui joe biden
qualifiant poutine de boucher jugeant
qu'il ne pouvait pas rester au pouvoir
sont-elles nécessaires pour isoler
davantage moscou bruno bien au contraire
est ce que tel de d'empêcher toute forme
de négociation paille à plusieurs il ya
plusieurs hypothèses possibles soit on
estime que joe biden est un président un
peu âgé et fatigué
qu'il a fait une gaffe mais en même
temps le terme boucher bon et très
violent faut se rappeler qu'il avait
déjà traité de deux meurtriers 1 il y a
quelques mois pendant pendant la
campagne électorale
pendant six filles peuvent être boucher
s'était pas pendant son discours boucher
c'est quand il avait été mis aux arrêts
réfugiés ukrainienne dans le stade en
pologne donc il était vraiment pris par
l'émotion mais s'il ya quelques jours en
fait oui tout à fait mais je crois qu'il
aurait dit ça dans le dans le discours à
dans le discours on a froid voilà voilà
froid oui c'était il répondait voilà
donc la question c'est est-ce que
c'était prémédité ou est ce que c'est
une erreur à ce que c est ce que c'est
une gaffe il ya certaines analyses qui
explique parce qu'ensuite liebling
canadien pleurait trop et aussi la
phrase sur le changement de régime le
sorte un là où il a dit cet homme là là
il l'a dit cet homme là ne peut pas
rester en place
ça peut être aussi un jeu de rôle si
vous voulez parce que certains
spécialistes estiment en fait que
vladimir poutine en fait il ne respecte
que la force et que en fait avoir et
puis joe biden cesser le dirigeant du
plus grand pays donc le fait qu il le
prête de cette manière là finalement
poutine ça n'impressionne pas vraiment
et il respecte plutôt ceux qui ont un
langage extrêmement ferme certains
disques par zones ce que fait manuel
macro poutine c'est pas ici c'est pas
vraiment sérieux en fait le saut lui
permet de gagner un peu de temps à
poutine mais en fait ils ne respectent
pas vraiment il respecte ce langage de
la force et répartition des rôles parce
que lui anthony blinken ensuite adoucit
un peu les les angles parce que c'est le
chef de la diplomatie et il dit non non
le changement de régime n'est pas n'est
pas dans notre dans nos objectifs mais
enfin le message est passé y compris
vis-à-vis de vladimir poutine ça sert
quels objectifs d'inquiéter vadimir
poutine c'est ça hein visiblement à que
cherche à faire joe biden je suis pas
sûr que ce soit ça je crois que joe
biden exprime là sont sont
des coûts sont sa perplexité par rapport
à ce qu'est cette attaque depuis
le 24 février je crois qu'il est il est
vraiment là pas de calcul pour vous
donner un calcul mais peut-être mais en
tout cas on a aussi côté russe ce double
ce binôme avec lavrov le ministre des
affaires étrangères qui on s'en souvient
la semaine dernière justement même si
c'est vrai que poutine ne respecte sans
doute pas vraiment emmanuel macron et
ses efforts diplomatiques mais lavrov
avait nommé emmanuel macron et savez est
vraiment surpris tout le monde en disant
qu' heureusement qu emmanuel macron
était là pour justement faire ce qu'il
était en train de faire donc des deux
côtés de toute façon il ya un jeu de
langage pour gagner du temps et en
attendant que quand même sur le terrain
militairement les choses bougent alors
que et c'est ça qui va déterminer
finalement les négociations c est ce que
cette histoire est ce que ça sera tout
ça pour ça c'est à dire tout c'est quand
même dizaines de milliers de morts
aujourd'hui avec des milliers de morts
militaires plus que civil sans doute moi
j'ai couvert des guerres dans lesquelles
il y avait beaucoup plus de morts civils
là on est dans d une guerre où il ya
énormément de morts militaires ne m'en
russe terre côté ukrainien peu et
énormément côté russe on donc ça il faut
il faut le souligner est ce que ça sera
suffisant pour que vladimir poutine
retourne vers le vert les limites avant
le 24 février qui sont à l'intérieur
d'une basse et qu'on puisse discuter
alors n'est pas l'arrêt pourrait ben moi
je reste quand même joli et du calcul
parce que je pense que dans les cercles
américains quand même il pense qu'en
fait le le fond du fond de la motivation
de vladimir poutine c'est la
préservation de son pouvoir lui de son
système politique à lui donc lui envoyer
un message en lui disant qu'il pourrait
ne pas rester au pouvoir ça peut
peut-être le déstabiliser et l'amener ça
peut être ça le calcul à négocier parce
qu'en fait on se rappelait quand même
qu'à chaque fois qu'il ya comme ça des
crises extérieures en 2008 en 2014 et
maintenant il y avait aussi des
motivations de politique intérieure pour
vladimir poutine soit parce qu'ils
traversaient des difficultés soit parce
qu'il organisait sa succession avec
medvedev soit parce que là ils étaient
en chute dans les sondages donc il ya
quand même sans jamais oublier pour la
nuit routine l'essentiel comme c'est de
préserver son pour durer à lui est de
préserver le système politique tel qu'il
est et qu'il ne devienne surtout pas un
système démocratique je crois pas qu'une
chute poutine serait dû à une action du
côté américain je pense que le
changement de régime à moscou c'est
peut-être ce que souhaite oui j'aime
bien ça suffisait mais c'est bien ça
sera ça sera lent ça sera long et ça
sera une affaire de trahison humaine
comme depuis les faits ce négociant
l'appareil sert de tête autre
préoccupation des américains renforcer
les liens entre israël et une partie du
monde arabe elle y est sous donald trump
1 du nom des désaccords d'abraham des
accords toujours bien vivant si l'on en
croit le chef de la diplomatie
américaine sous l'actuelle
administration démocrate anthony blinken
en tournée dans la région assister à un
sommet du néguev l'occasion pour lui de
rappeler l'importance d'une solution à
deux états à écouter
les états unis ont éventé continuer à
soutenir avec force ce processus qui
transforme la région et au delà mais
dans le même temps nous devons être
clairs sur le fait que ces accords de
paix régionaux ne doivent pas se
substituer aux progrès entre les
israéliens et les palestiniens
nous avons notamment discuté de comment
les pays engagés dans les accords
d'abraham et la normalisation ainsi que
ceux qui ont des relations diplomatiques
de longue date avec israël peuvent
soutenir l'autorité palestinienne et les
palestiniens de manière concrète et
avoir un impact positif sur la vie des
palestiniens en cisjordanie et à gaza
merci à l'avant différents saint-bruno
par rapport à l'accord scellé sous
donald trump il ne se fera pas sur le
dos ou en oubliant les palestiniens
cali est ce que dit anthony blinken oui
alors d'abord quand même ce qu'il faut
dire c'est que de fait là
l'administration by dunn est en train de
valider ce qui a été fait par donald
trump ce qui a été une des principales
actions de moi-même de donald trump
cette espèce de remodelage le début de
remodelage des des rapports de forces au
proche orient là c'est quand même avec
le déplacement dans tony blinken c'est
totalement validé donc c'est la première
chose effectivement ensuite il ménage un
peu la chèvre et le chou donc anthony
blinken est également allé à ramallah
voir l'autorité palestinienne mais
franchement y compris dans la
déclaration qu'on a entendu la voyez
qu'on parle de moyens d'améliorer en
fait c'est ça maintenant hélas un peu
pour les palestiniens les moyens
d'améliorer la vie quotidienne des
palestiniens mais il ya plus du tout de
d'objectifs politiques c'est à dire sur
la création réellement d'un état
palestinien donc disons que par rapport
à l'administration trappe la mission
maiden reste plus classique d'un point
de vue diplomatique est plus poli mais
sur le contenu moi je trouve qu'il ya
pas grand chose d'autre à vianne oui il
n'ya pas grand chose sauf que quand même
on a on aille à 16 il ya le problème de
ce qui se passe avec les accords en iran
sur l'iran sur le nucléaire iranien mais
je parlais des palestiniens oui oui tout
à fait mais et là il ya quand même une
impression de la part de ceux qui
participaient au sommet aujourd'hui qui
sont dans des alliés des etats-unis que
une relance de cet accord serait que
comme un abandon finalement donc les on
voit bien que les etats unis aujourd'hui
leur priorité ça n'est plus justement le
moyen-orient le proche orient sané même
c'est même pas énormément non plus cette
guerre qui nous préoccupe nous en europe
ils l'ont dit à mots couverts et
emmanuel macron une fois de plus cela
dit nous on est beaucoup plus proche de
la russie donc on est beaucoup plus
préoccupé donc du coup ça change ça
modifie complètement la politique
étrangère des états unis ça je crois que
c'est ce qu'il faut noter alors c'est
intéressant quand tony blinken était là
aujourd'hui mais
il ya une angoisse de la part des
représentants et une présence au complet
retrouvez
également son plein tout à fait l'iran
on pensait qu'avec temps le permet les
accords d'abraham
ça permet aux états unis quand même
d'être un peu le parent ce qu'ils ont
dit ce qu'ils ont été de cette drôle
d'alliance au départ entre israël et les
pays arabes notamment les émirats arabes
unis mais plus sacrifier le nucléaire
iranien l'accord sur le mécanisme unir
contre les velléités expansionnistes de
l'iran ce qui m angoisse de cpj
attention il ya quand même les rebelles
houthistes au yémen qui sont soutenus
par l'iran qui sont en train d'attaquer
l'arabie saoudite et émirats arabes unis
et là franchement les américains sont
pas vraiment là pour les défendre et
donc c'est compliqué c'est ambigu merci
à merci également à vous bruno c'était
on va plus loin on se retrouve dans
moins de trois minutes pour un nouveau
journal dans paris